[Music]
i also love that you're a part of this
taylor swift video
[Music]
how did this come about um taylor and i
from youtube you know that's the crazy
thing about youtube is that anybody can
upload a video and somebody can see it
and i uploaded a video called for taylor
she found it we became bffs and then she
called me and said i'm working on this
project that's super secret but i know i
can trust you will you not tell anyone
and i didn't tell anyone it was the best
it felt like christmas came early
because when it came out my phone blew
up more than it ever has before and
everybody was freaking out about it and
such an epic and iconic video to be a
part of it's so memorable you guys have
a memorable memorable part in it i'm not
just saying this because you're here
this dance break might be my favorite
part of the video because obviously
you're featured in it but it's also
we've never seen taylor like this and in
fact i think we have a clip we're going
to play real quick of the epic choreo
look what you made me do look what you
made me do look what you just made me do
look what you just made
look what you made me do look what you
made me do look what you just made
[Music]
and i just want you to know that is the
first and only time you're ever going to
see me in a crop top so screenshot that
making your screens everywhere it's
never happening again i had no idea
that's what i was going to be wearing i
was super into it but um i was very very
nervous i've never done anything like
that before in my entire life so what
was your reaction when you realized not
only would you be wearing a crop top but
it said i heart ts we've seen that we've
seen those pictures we've seen them yeah
what do you think um i just thought it
was brilliant she's just such an iconic
and epic person and whatever she
whatever she puts her hands on always
turns to gold and i love the fact that
she expresses how she feels through her
music as opposed to on twitter on social
media it's always done in such an epic
and creative way and i just really
appreciate any artist that does that
that's why i'm such a huge beyonce fan
um and taylor is definitely um raising
the bar and everybody else better take
notes okay it's true man i mean how much
about how much did you know about the
video and the concept before signing on
um i didn't know very much about it and
i understood why she wasn't able to tell
me a lot because it was a huge project
and so close to her and she filmed it so
much before it came out so i respected
that and completely was like i trust
that you're going to put me in a
positive light and that the video is
going to be amazing i would have never
dreamed that it was going to be breaking
all of these records so quickly um but
i'm just so proud of her because she's
such an amazing person on the inside and
out she's treated me so kindly she came
to see me in kinky boots was so sweet to
everybody i've never seen her be
anything less than an angel she's like a
living breathing like cinderella like
from walt disney world or something so
it's really cool just to get watch her
shine like that and be able to express
herself through her music and it's
exciting and you know what this is the
first time we've seen taylor do some
serious choreography like this
absolutely she brought it i mean how
impressed were you by her i was so
impressed because no shade to other
people in the industry but there are a
lot of people who try to dance but with
her it seems very natural we've had a
lot of experience taylor and i dancing
at the club so i knew that she had what
it took but sometimes it's difficult to
translate your your club dancing to your
on camera dancing and i thought she did
such an amazing job at it she was like
so like kick-ass and we didn't film it
that many times she just killed it every
single performance how many takes was
that not a lot i mean they obviously did
a lot of camera moves but she um she she
just nailed it every time we didn't have
to go back because she was messing up
choreography she was it was just a very
i mean i've worked with beyonce and i've
gotten to work with taylor and it was a
very similar thing she's a perfectionist
she was never going to go out on camera
and not show herself in the best light
and i thought she was amazing for your
first time ever dancing that looks like
she's been dancing her entire life you
can tell she did her homework like you
guys must have put in a lot of work
rehearsal time yeah right yeah well we
didn't get a lot of rehearsal you didn't
know she had rehearsed with the
choreographer i think a little bit
beforehand but i love the fact that she
takes so much pride and appreciates the
art form that is the dancing and what we
do and like wanted to make sure that her
dancing was at the same level as the
dancers and i think she accomplished
that i'm so proud of her that's amazing
you know with any piece of art it's open
to interpretation right yeah and i feel
like there's been a lot of talk about
who or what she's referencing i want to
know from you what do you think the
message is she's trying to get across
with this particular video
i'm not sure what the message that she's
trying to get across
is i don't know and i don't necessarily
want to speak on that but i just think
that whatever it is that she's trying to
get across i like i said i love the fact
that she's saying it through her music
through her lyrics and that it's all
metaphors so that it can be open for
interpretation and that she like
you know bedazzled the video with all of
these little easter eggs and it's like a
where's waldo like live video where you
have to go back and keep watching it to
see all the hidden messages and stuff
and i really really love that because
you know so many people have made epic
videos but not very many people make
videos that you have to go back and
watch a million times so that you can
get all the references i just think it's
so genius i'm so inspired by her and um
when she says look what you made me do
she means look what you made me do you
made me break records you made me sell
more records than everyone else you made
me like get the most views that anyone
has ever gotten on youtube in 24 hours
she got over 40 million views it's just
really really insane it's awesome
because she's also kind of poking fun at
herself yeah her former selves you know
and and and she's telling people i'm you
know what i am part of this narrative
and i'm doing it i love it i'm doing it
well and any artists should be able to
laugh at themselves and to be able to
recognize the things that people say to
them and spin it on its head i love that
that's what i love about rupaul's drag
race and drag queens and i love t that's
probably i love taylor so much and
that's why people love taylor yeah she's
able to laugh at herself she has a great
sense of humor